notstand so haben wir die aktuelle
situation in unserer neuen ausgabe
genannt und auch wenn das leben für die
meisten können uns noch einigermaßen
normal weitergeht wir hier bei der faz
arbeiten noch ganz normal noch so hat
das virus die welt doch schon ganz schön
auf den kopf gestellt italien zum
beispiel ist abgeriegelt israel auch und
donald trump hat für europäer ein
einreiseverbot verhängt
die cases from entering the spending
travel von united states von der nextel
die ds und auch in deutschland legt die
bundesregierung mehr und mehr das
öffentliche leben lahm
nur welchen plan verfolgt sie dabei das
haben wir julia löhr gefragt sie ist
wirtschaftskorrespondentin in berlin und
die aktion die titelgeschichte
geschrieben
hier in berlin lautet im moment die
devise vor allem zeit gewinnen soll
verhindert werden dass sich innerhalb
kurzer zeit viele menschen an dem virus
anstecken und die krankenhäuser an ihre
belastungsgrenze kommen deshalb also
keine veranstaltungen mehr mit 1000
teilnehmern so der rat von
bundesgesundheitsminister ganz sparen
auch kleinere veranstaltungen überdenken
auch sonst sich überlegen was man privat
welcher treffen veranstaltungen machen
will und welche nicht
hier in berlin geht das leben gerade er
noch so seinen normalen gang wir haben
sitzungswoche im parlament es finden
nach wie vor veranstaltungen statt aber
es ist gut möglich dass das auch hier
nächste woche dann schnell zum erliegen
kommt sind diese maßnahme überhaupt
verhältnismäßig oder müsste eigentlich
zum wohle aller
sogar der totale shutdown her wenn sie
mehr erfahren wollen nehmen sie sich ein
paar minuten und lesen sie die woche